183 coureurs partaient à l'assaut de la
colline elancourt ce week-end pour le
titre régional de vtt ufolep
au programme trois tours de 8 km un
dénivelé positif de 164 m et un départ à
couper le souffle
dès les premiers tours de roue les
coureurs devaient faire face à la bosse
de la colline où les plus forts
pourcentages atteignent 18 % il devait
ensuite s'extraire des passages en forêt
encore très humide
bref un combat de tous les instants sur
24 km c'était compliqué partout il
fallait bien gérer mais il y avait une
partie très collante très boueuse vers
l'antenne où il ya une descente très
sélective où il fallait passer à pied on
n'avait pas trop le choix
et du coup c'est vrai que c'était
c'était difficile crevaison panne de
dérailleur chaîne cassée les abandons se
comptent par dizaines
la faute à un tracé extrêmement boueux
et pour s'imposer il fallait partir en
costaud à l'image de l'expérimentée
arrivés vers titre i chez les seniors en
fait j'ai attaqué goût de la deuxième
côte sur le bitume
parce que je voulais vraiment partir
tout seul
géré ma course et pas me regarder les
arcs adversaire qui était derrière
après ce marathon passer la ligne est un
soulagement et leur ravitaillement à la
buvette plutôt salvateur